[Musik]
ich wurde Anfang der 80er Jahre Polizist
Kapitalverbrechen interessierten mich
schon immer
ich würde Leiter des Dezernats für Mord
und organisierte Kriminalität in
Cambridge
[Musik]
ich habe dutzende von Verdächtigen
Todesfällen untersucht darunter an die
30 Morde
first die ersten zwei bis drei Tage
einer morduntersuchung sind extrem
fordernd als leitender Ermittler trägt
man die volle Verantwortung
dies ist nicht der Tatort sondern der
Fundort
hier hat der Täter die Leiche vergraben
um davon zu kommen
vielleicht hat er den Mord absolut
ungesehen begangen vielleicht hat er
keinerlei Spuren hinterlassen die zum
Tatort führen
über die nächsten Tage wälzt man als
Ermittler rund um die Uhr fieberhaft
alle Fakten die man hat
ich glaube man geht selbst nachts im
Bett den Fall durch
er nimmt einen vollkommen in Beschlag es
gibt den Großbritannien wenige Morde die
nicht aufgeklärt wurden als leitender
Ermittler willst du nicht dass dein Fall
dazugehört
[Musik]
eine blutige Fehde
[Applaus]
Leute die sich hassen ich warne dich
wovor mein Mann wird es euch zeigen der
Mord war der grausame Abschluss
wie sie ihre Spuren verwischten
um uns auf die falsche Fährte zu lenken
das war von langer Hand geplant
am 22 November 2006 wurde Andrews
kennline von seiner Freundin Luis als
vermisst gemeldet
ich kann ihn seit vier Tagen nicht
erreichen er antwortet nicht auf meine
Nachrichten
keiner etwas von ihm gehört
[Musik]
35 Jahre alt er war arbeitslos und hatte
immer wieder Probleme mit der Polizei
ein Kleinkrimineller
der war phasenweise heroinabhängig
wo der Beleuchtung aber einfach zu
verschwinden sei ihm nicht ähnlich
[Musik]
Louis machte sich Sorgen
deshalb meldete sie ihn als vermisst
[Musik]
am 17 November hatte er ihr nachts
geschrieben dass er mit Freunden nach
London gefahren war und in ein paar
Tagen zurück sein würde
sie fragte sich mit wem er unterwegs war
und was er dort machte
[Musik]
am Abend des 17 November hatte ein
Freund namens Peter Luis und Andrew zu
Hause besucht
sie waren zu dritt in dem Haus
meine Kollegen Befragten beide zu dem
vermisstenfalls machte widersprüchliche
Aussagen
er antwortet nicht
zuerst sagte sie zwei Männer hätten
Andrew mit einem roten Auto abgeholt ja
es waren zwei dann dass sie nicht wisse
wer ihn abgeholt habe ihre Schilderung
war chaotisch
dann habe ich Peter angerufen
ihre Geschichte ergab keinen Sinn
Peters Bericht war auch chaotisch er
wirkte verwirrt was vermuten ließ dass
er etwas mit dem Verschwinden zu tun
hatte
Louis und Peter galten von Anfang an als
verdächtig
[Musik]
wann haben sie ihn zuletzt gesehen sie
wurden getrennt vernommen dann bin ich
heimgegangen
Luis sagte dass Andrew seine Bankkarte
mitgenommen hätte
ganz sicher wir haben die Bank
kontaktiert
als die Bankkarte zuletzt verwendet
wurde hat der Geldautomat ein Foto
gemacht und darauf
war Peter zu sehen
peter wurde am 22 November verhaftet er
hatte Andrews Bankkarte bei sich wir
vermuteten dass er gemeinsam mit Luis in
den Vermisstenfall verstrickt war
als wir Sie bezüglich des abgehobenen
Geldes Befragten sagten beide aus dass
Andrews kennline Peter die Erlaubnis
gegeben hatte sein Gehalt auf Andrews
Konto einzahlen zu lassen
hatte kein Konto und gerade einen neuen
Job angefangen er brauchte ein Konto um
sein Gehalt zu bekommen das verringerte
den Verdacht gegenüber den beiden
wir waren in einer Sackgasse gelandet
ihre Aussagen hatten uns auf die falsche
Fährte geführt wir mussten noch einmal
neu ansetzen
[Musik]
Louis berichtete uns das Andrew am 17
November zu James und Marc basement ins
Auto gestiegen war seinen Halbbrüdern
[Musik]
sie hätten ihm gesagt dass ihre Mutter
ihm in ihrem Testament Geld hinterlassen
habe
überglücklich an etwas Geld zu kommen
es hieß das sie gemeinsam an die
Südküste fahren müssten um dort den
Rechtsanwalt zu treffen der ihnen die
Summe aushändigen würde
Luis hat gesehen wie Andrew in der
dicken Street in den Ford Escort
Einstieg
[Musik]
dann fuhren sie los
wir haben die Mobilfunkdaten von Mark
basement und von Andrews überprüft
wie sich herausstellte waren die Brüder
wohl tatsächlich gemeinsam mit Andrew
von dieser Adresse losgefahren
und an Luises Geschichte war etwas dran
Brüder Mark und James in den Fokus
unserer Ermittlungen
Andrew wurde bereits seit einem Monat
vermisst Menschen verschwinden nicht
einfach ihr war etwas passiert
offensichtlich hatten die Belgian Brüder
Andrew als letzte lebend gesehen
[Musik]
als wir Informationen zu Mark basement
einholten stellte sich heraus dass er
einiges auf dem Kerbholz hatte
er wurde wegen eines bewaffneten
Raubüberfalls zu viereinhalb Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt damals war er 18 er
war ein verurteilter Gewaltverbrecher
allerdings war Mark eher ein Mitläufer
sein Bruder war der Anführer der beiden
james war 30 Jahre alt verheiratet und
hatte zwei Kinder
[Musik]
guten Tag entschuldigen Sie die Störung
wir fahren nach einer vermissten Person
Andrews
okay kennen sie er ist mein Halbbruder
wann haben sie ihn zum letzten Mal
gesehen
als die Polizei Mark und James befragte
leugneten sie ihren Halbbruder am 17
November in der dicken Street abgeholt
zu haben
ich habe Andrew lange nicht gesehen dass
wir das sprach Louises Aussage er wird
vermisst das hat uns misstrauisch
gemacht und unsere Sorge um Andrew
verstärkt
könnten wir Sie dazu nochmals befragen
ja klar
ich musste die Prioritäten für meine
Ermittlerteam festlegen
erstens mussten wir die Bewegung in der
baysion-brüder nachvollziehen wo waren
sie weshalb und mit wem
wir haben Andrews Handy am 17 November
getrackt
wo war er wen hat er angerufen welche
Nachrichten hat er verschickt und welche
Route hat er zurückgelegt
[Musik]
haben die Mobilfunkdaten von Mark James
und Andrew ausgewertet und abgeglichen
es gab eine genaue Übereinstimmung
offensichtlich waren alle drei von Peter
borrow über die M25 nach erderstadt
gefahren
wurde von Andrews Handy die letzte SMS
verschickt
das war die Nachricht an seine Freundin
dass er nach London fahren würde dass
seine Freunde ihn abgesetzt hätten und
er für ein paar Tage dort sein würde
danach wurde sein Handy nicht mehr
genutzt
bei einer Anwohnerbefragung in
erderschott kam heraus dass Andrews
gesehen wurde
und zwar mit zwei Personen deren
Beschreibung seinen Halbbrüdern
entsprach und einer dritten Person bei
der es sich wohl um Jeff Woods handelte
viel im Wald er war Baumpfleger von
Beruf
wie sich zeigte hatte er die Brüder im
Verlauf des 17 November getroffen
das war an James Bay Jones Wohnhaus
dann war er mit den beigen Brüdern und
Andrews gefahren
vom dritten januar 2007 folgte die
vorläufige Festnahme der drei
Verdächtigen Mark beyond
James bayjant
und Jeff woods
alle drei wurden zu Andrews verschwinden
befragt
wo waren sie am 17 November
sie wissen nicht mehr wo sie waren
sie haben keine meiner Fragen
beantwortet
komm kein Kommentar
sie sagten nur kein Kommentar
[Musik]
kein Kommentar
gar keiner
ich war sehr besorgt denn wahrscheinlich
wussten nur die drei wo Andrews
Kennenlern war
und wenn alle drei mauerten hatten wir
keine Chance ihn zu finden
[Musik]
kein Kommentar
wir hatten sie seit 36 Stunden in
Gewahrsam und bereits mehrfach
verlängert uns lief die Zeit davon
wir brauchten stechhaltige Beweise
andernfalls mussten wir die drei wieder
freilassen
wir die maximale Dauer einer vorläufigen
Festnahme bereits ausgereizt
mit seinem Anwalt zu uns und meinte ich
muss Ihnen etwas sagen
[Musik]
plötzlich begann Jeff Woods mit uns zu
reden
ich habe überhaupt nichts damit zu tun
sie müssen mit den Brüdern sprechen
beginnen wir mit Ihnen erzählen Sie mir
was sie wissen
er bestätigte uns das Andrews ermordet
wurde sie haben ihn gehasst aber sie
konnten nichts machen solange ihre
Mutter noch am Leben waren Mut sagte
dass er den Mord nicht begangen hatte
aber er hatte dabei geholfen die Leiche
zu verscharren
ich zeige Ihnen wo
und er war gewillt und die Stelle zu
zeigen
darauf nichts mit dem Mord zu tun zu
haben
das Grab auszuheben die Leiche
hineinzulegen und sie mit Erde zu
bedecken
er wollte uns zuerst seine Geschichte
erzählen
sie was
bevor sie ihn besichtigen konnten
im Anschluss haben wir Jeff Wutz in
einem Polizeikonvoi zu der Stelle
gefahren wo Andrews canlan laut ihm
begraben wurde
er würde uns nicht die ganze Wahrheit
erzählen
welche Rolle spielte er wirklich wusste
er wo die Leiche begraben war oder
wollte er nur auf Zeit spielen
ich wusste es nicht
gefesselt da
Anwalt in einem Polizeiwagen und Lotte
unsere Kolonne zu der angegebenen Stelle
die Zeit Rente
wir mussten in den Kürze freilassen
ich hatte keine Ahnung ob Jeff Woods uns
anlogsversuch
wollte er mit uns raus aufs Land fahren
um das Weite zu suchen
[Musik]
als wir hier entlang liefen dachte ich
weder kenne ich mich hier aus noch Jeff
Woods der hat doch keine Ahnung wo die
Leiche ist
ich vermisstrauisch und vermutete die
ganze Zeit das what's fliehen wollte
die Gegend nicht zu kennen
und erschien sich nicht zu erinnern wo
genau die Leiche lag
er wollte uns überzeugen dass er nichts
mit dem Mord zu tun gehabt hatte nur mit
der Entsorgung der Leiche
denn darauf steht eine wesentlich
geringere Strafe
er ist zögerlich vorausgegangen wenn man
durch das Tor kommt sieht man noch nicht
ob der Pfad irgendwo hinführt
[Musik]
wir durchquerten das Gelände dann zeigte
Jeff Woods auf einen Mülleimer
da haben wir die Handschuhe reingeworfen
Platz welche Handschuhe
sie haben mich gezwungen Gummihandschuhe
anzuziehen als ich das Grabschaufeln
musste
wir fanden drei Gummihandschuhe darin
er war also tatsächlich dort gewesen
wir hatten die ganze Zeit im Hinterkopf
dass er diese Gelegenheit zur Flucht
nutzen könnte
vielleicht hatte er uns auf eine
sinnlose Schnitzeljagd in den Wald
geführt um sich aus dem Staub zu machen
er hatte unser Zelt dass er mitten in
der Nacht von James einen Anruf erhielt
die Brüder hätten ihn mit einer Waffe
bedroht und ihn nach Sandy hell gefahren
da sei ihm klar geworden dass etwas
Übles passiert war
auf diesem Erdhügel
[Musik]
habe eine Leiche gelegen
Jeff habe gewusst dass es sich um Andrew
handelte aber er habe nichts mit dem
Mord zu tun gehabt er sei lediglich dazu
gezwungen worden dieses Loch zu graben
die gleiche hineinzulegen und es
aufzufüllen
hier sind wir entlang gegangen
ich sah die Stelle im Halbschatten der
Bäume
wir waren nur etwa zehn Meter entfernt
Jeff stand dort ich hier er sah uns an
und sagte da ist die Leiche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als ich mir die Stelle ansah wurde mir
klar dass dort nicht nur ein sondern
zwei Gräber waren
[Musik]
wir haben das gesamte Gelände abgesperrt
in der Hoffnung forensische Beweise zu
finden die den basic-brüdern und Jeff
Woods zuzuordnen waren
[Musik]
der Leichnam war stark verweist er war
seit fast zwei Monaten in der Erde aber
die zahnärztlichen Befunde zeigten dass
es sich um Andrews
[Musik]
die Todesursache war nicht eindeutig
der Tote wurde oberhalb des Unterkiefers
geköpft zudem wurden beide Hände
abgehakt der Torso vom Unterkiefer bis
zu den handlosen Armen lag in einer
kleinen Grube einige Meter weiter Lagen
der Kopf und die Hände in einem zweiten
Grab
[Musik]
wir konnten scanlands Kleidung
sicherstellen
in seinem Nacken entdeckten wir eine
farbliche Markierung an der Stelle an
der man ihn mit einer Waffe den Kopf
abgetrennt hatte
später fanden wir auch in seinem
Rückenmark Farbrückstände von dieser
Waffe
[Musik]
der Gerichtsmediziner stellte fest dass
kenlern vor seinem Tod brutal
zusammengeschlagen wurde
[Musik]
wir beschlagnahmten die Handys der drei
Verdächtigen
auf James Handy fanden wir eine
Nachricht an seine Frau schalet die
lautete wir haben ihn
[Musik]
James und Mark basement haben sich
vehement geweigert mit der Polizei zu
kooperieren und uns auch nur eine
Information zu geben
während Chef Woods uns eine Version der
Geschichte auf tischte die ihn vom
Mordverdacht befreien sollte sie werden
es auf mich schämen ich habe nichts
damit zu tun
nun hatten wir eine Nachricht die auch
charlotteed belastete
scheinbar war sie in das Mordkomplott
verwickelt
wir lesen sie verhaften und aufs Revier
bringen
[Musik]
ich und ich haben nichts damit zu tun
sie hat alles abgestritten sie sagte sie
wissen nichts von einem Mordkomplott
ihres Mannes oder Schwagers und sei in
nichts verwickelt gewesen
s Auto
wir suchten nach DNA-Spuren von scanlern
und anderen Indizien wie Stofffasern die
zeigten dass er in diesem Wagen gesessen
hatte
und zwar in der Nacht in der ermordet
wurde
die Polizei hatte das Fahrzeug von James
bagon beschlagnahmt
man hat es bereits auf DNA-Spuren von
biologischem Material untersucht
hofften wir Fasern zu finden die zeigen
würden dass Andrew scandline in dem
Wagen gesessen hatte
wir suchten ewig
Jeff Woods und Andrew scanland trugen
beide Kleidung aus
schliesst
sprich dass ich leicht Kunstfasern lösen
hunderte oder tausende von
faserrückständen auf den Autositzen zu
finden
auf der Folie waren kaum Fasern zu sehen
das sagte mir dass der Wagen gründlich
gereinigt wurde um alle Rückstände zu
beseitigen
jemand könnte sich aus
und hat eine forensische Reinigung
vorgenommen damit die Polizei keinerlei
Spuren finden würde
[Musik]
bei einer Befragung der Anwohner fanden
wir Zeugen die gesehen hatten wie die
Brüder den weißen Ford Escort penibel
gereinigt hatten
sie berichteten dass die Brüder die
Sätze mit Klebebändern bearbeitet hatten
um jegliche Rückstände zu entfernen
die Zeugen hatten auch beobachtet dass
James bays Frau Charlotte bei der
Reinigung half
vielleicht war Charlotte nicht in die
Tat an sich verwickelt aber sie hat
definitiv bei der Beseitigung der Spuren
geholfen damit wir Ihnen nicht auf die
Schliche kommen würden
James Mark und charlotted haben einiges
unternahmen damit die Polizei keine
Beweise findet
doch die Spurensicherung ist ihnen einen
Schritt voraus
extrem schwierig alle faserrückstände
verschwinden zu lassen
so gründlich sie auch vorgegangen sein
mögen es war nicht perfekt
auf dem mittleren Rücksitz fand ich vier
Polyesterfasern die eindeutig von
Andrews gamlines Fleecejacke stammten
[Musik]
die Fasern waren nur 0,5 bis 2 mm lang
und nicht mit bloßem Auge sichtbar
diese Rückstände stimmten mit der
Kleidung überein die Andrews Kennenlern
an dem Tag trug und die wir bei seinem
Torso gefunden hatten
[Musik]
damit konnten wir beweisen dass
kennenlernen in diesem Wagen entführt
und schließlich ermordet wurde in der
Nacht vom 17 November 2006
[Musik]
als wir dann die Hausdurchsuchungen
vorgenommen haben fanden wir mehrere
Dutzend DVDs der Fernsehserie CSI Vegas
war ein Fan der Serie
bei ihm fanden wir eine Axt
stimmte die Farbe mit den Farbspuren ans
Hals überein
aber wir brauchten weitere Beweise und
ein Mordmotiv
dann fanden wir Zeugen die auf einer
Party gewesen waren
eine Woche nach dem Andrew verschwunden
war feierte Charlotte basement ihren
Geburtstag
das ist meine Party okay
sie war betrunken begann sich mit einem
ihrer Gäste zu streiten
und drohte dann dessen Freundin
beim nächsten Mal kriegt er es mit
meinem Mann zu tun
ach ja
sie sagte dass Janine töten würde
er hat das schon mal gemacht die Gäste
glaubt mir nicht und stachelten sie an
wen hat er umgebracht
Andrew klar und wo Schale bei ihnen
im Detail ausgeplaudert wie ihr Mann
seinen Halbbruder Andrews kennen getötet
hat und die kriegen euch nicht niemals
Charlotte basement hat geprallt dass sie
UV-Lampen besäße und sich mit
tatort-arbeit auskennen würde
beseitigt
dass sie genau wüsste wie man
forensische Beweise vernichtet ich kenne
mich aus
charlotte hat einen schlimmen Fehler
begangen sie hat ihre mitwissenschaft
zugegeben
und sie hat ihren Mann als Mörder
entlarvt
[Musik]
haben sie angehalten
in der Nacht vom 17 auf den 18 November
haben sie ihren Wagen hier geparkt
Andrew hielt es für eine Pinkelpause
[Musik]
wir wissen dass sie einen
Baseballschläger und eine Axt benutzt
haben
er muss beides gesehen haben
[Musik]
er rannte um sein Leben
um sein Leben
[Musik]
James hat mit dem Baseballschläger auf
seinen Halbbruder eingeschlagen weder
und weder Max sagte der Bastard will
nicht sterben also hat er ihn am Hals
gepackt und ihm das Genick gebrochen
genau
der Gerichtsmediziner stellte fest dass
Andrew vor seinem Tod misshandelt wurde
doch danach widersprechen sich die
Aussagen
mit den forensischen beweisen den
Zeugenaussagen und dem Geständnis von
Jeff Woods können Sie den Fall vor
Gericht bringen
der Gerichtssaal war voll die
trefferdächtigen saßen zusammen auf der
Anklagebank getrennt von
gefängniswörtern die Atmosphäre war
angespannt
wurde die Geschichte noch vertrauter
erzählten nun eine völlig andere
Geschichte
sie sagten sie seien mit Andrews
Kennenlern in den Wald gegangen um sich
mit ihm einen Spaß zu erlauben
sie hätten ihm die Klamotten ausziehen
und ihn frierend im Wald zurücklassen
wollen
doch zuerst hätten sie sich erleichtert
als sie zurückkamen hätten sie gesehen
wie Jeff Woods Andrews kennenlernen
dann hätten sie Woods geholfen scanland
zu begraben
[Musik]
am Tod ihres Halbbruders hätten sie
keine Schuld
und er hat wir hatten zwei
widersprüchliche Aussagen
Jeff Watts beschuldigte die
belgien-brüder und die Beschuldigten
jethroods
aber wir hatten eine Zeugin ausfindig
gemacht die beide Schilderungen
widerlegen und uns die Wahrheit
berichten konnte
die dritte Version die sich mit den
gesicherten Fakten deckte lieferte uns
Mandy azomadiedes
sie berichtete uns im Detail was Mark
basement ihr erzählt hatte
kurz nachdem sie Andrews kennline
entführt und ermordet hatten fuhr Mark
beigen mit Mandy nach Griechenland in
den Urlaub
sie fuhren die ganze Strecke zu zweit
mit dem Auto quer durch Europa
[Musik]
im Laufe der Fahrt hat er ihr genau
berichtet wie sie Andrews kennenlernen
umgebracht hatten
laut ihr prügelten sie mit einem
Baseballschläger auf ihn ein
dann brachbagon seinem Halbbruder mit
einem Seil das Genick
Chef Woods hat mindestens zweimal auf
scanline eingestochen
danach haben sie den Toten zu einer
Grube gezerrt
ihn hineingelegt
abgedeckt und den Tatort verlassen
sie verschickten die SMS von seinem
Handy dann fuhren sie zu james-bations
House
wo sie ihre Kleidung und die Mordwaffen
an schalet übergaben
sie sollte alles entsorgen
eine Minderheit am nächsten Tag haben
die Basen Brüder mit Schale das Fahrzeug
gründlich gereinigt um alle Spuren zu
beseitigen
[Musik]
s Geständnis dass Sie sich Notizen
machte
so konnte sie detailliert zu Protokoll
geben wieder Mord an Andrews Kennenlern
geplant und durchgeführt wurde
[Musik]
es war uns wichtig dass keiner von ihnen
ungestraft davon kam denn wir wussten
dass alle drei diesen Mord begangen
hatten
im Laufe der Verhandlung kommen auch die
Motive der Mörder ans Licht
wurde mit 18 Jahren wegen bewaffneten
Raubüberfalls verhaftet er war immer
überzeugt gewesen dass Andrews kennline
ihn verpfiffen hatte und er seinetwegen
viereinhalb Jahre einsetzen musste Marc
und James bationed haben ihren
Halbbruder die Schuld gegeben
[Musik]
weder drängt sich mir die Frage auf
weshalb es zwei Gräber gab das machte
den Fall so skurril ich hatte einige
Morde bei denen dem Opfer Körperteile
abgetrennt wurden
normalerweise wird so etwas vom Täter
mitgenommen
wieso lagen sie wenige Meter weiter in
einem zweiten Grab
wir haben uns nie gebeichtet weshalb sie
die Leiche zerstückelt haben
ich habe die Vermutung dass sie auf
diese Weise die Identität der Leiche
verschleiern wollten
wahrscheinlich hatten sie vor
zurückzukommen Hände und Kopf
auszugraben und woanders zu verstecken
James bation galt als Kopf des
Mordkomplott und wurde zu lebenslänglich
nicht unter 24 Jahren verurteilt
Marc Base und hat ebenfalls eine
lebenslängliche Freiheitsstrafe nicht
unter 24 Jahren erhalten
Jeff Woods wurde zu einem Minimum von 20
Jahren verurteilt
[Musik]
wurde wegen Beihilfe zum Mord und
justizbehinderung angeklagt sie
plädierte in allen Punkten auf nicht
schuldig wurde aber verschuldigt
befunden und erhielt 12 Monate
wir hatten es mit einer blutigen Fehde
zu tun mit Hass und einem teuflischen
Komplott dass einem Mann 50 Meter
entfernt von hier das Leben kostete
angefangen mit einer Entführung 150 km
entfernt
der Fall zeigt wie grausam und skurril
Morde in der Realität sein können
[Musik]
neben den ausgehobenen Gräbern zu stehen
im schattigen Wald mutet wie ein
Horrorfilm an
und für das Opfer muss diese Mordnacht
ein einziger Albtraum gewesen sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]